heads up this video is full of spoilers
so during the Superbowl Netflix
announced that they were releasing a new
chlorophyll movie and then once the game
was over it actually came out that's
gotta be some kind of record I mean how
did they make all this special effects
that fast
anyway we watched the whole thing a ton
of time so that we could bring you this
video about all the connections JJ
Abrams / bad robot produced all three
movies in the clover verse as expected
he snuck in some of his famous Easter
eggs into the Cloverfield paradox
for example the name kelvin which has a
habit of popping up and a lot of his
projects like in the very first scene of
Cloverfield paradox when Ava and Michael
wait in line at a Kelvin gas station
we've seen one of these before
Michelle filled up at one at the
beginning of 10 Cloverfield Lane and
we've also seen the name in the opening
scene of Abrams Star Trek George Kirk
starship is known as the USS Kelvin and
in lost Kelvin was the name of the guy
who manned the Swan Dharma station
before Desmond the reason for Kelvin
popping up so many times in JJ Abrams
productions is because it is the last
name of his grandfather Henry and did
you catch the reference to the fictional
soft-drink slusho a very common easter
egg and definitely one of my favorites
this wobbly little guy on the dashboard
is holding a slusho cup this drink first
worked its way into an early episode of
the JJ Abrams produced series alias and
over the years it's been referenced in
fringe super 8 heroes and the first
Cloverfield in fact some of the very
first Cloverfield viral marketing
implied that extraction of nectar from
the seabed is what initially caused
monsters to awaken but of course now we
know better it was a particle
accelerator in space duh about that
particle accelerator they call it the
Sheppard now that could reference Alan
Shepard the second human ever in space
and the first American but seeing is how
it's an international mission this is
kind of a us-centric reference I prefer
to think of it as a shout-out to Jack
Shepard the protagonist of the bad robot
produced fantasy series lost
maybe this process is what also caused
things to go so wacky on that crazy
Island oh no right it was a purgatory Oh
when Michael's contact at the space
mission HQ in Huntsville who we hear him
talk to on the phone Joe remember him
that's the voice of
Greg Grunberg a childhood friend of JJ
Abrams who appears in a bunch of bad
robot productions in cameos
he's the doom pilot of oceanic flight
815 on lost a guest at Tom Cruise's
house party in Mission Impossible three
resistance pilot teman snapped Wexley in
the force awakens and he provides the
voice of James Kirk stepdad in the
rebooted Star Trek also Molly was
watching that weird little cartoon on
her tablet bleep blue almost looked like
it was about a little animated robot
maybe a bad robot or we may be pushing
this a little too far now
so in the new movie we're actually on
board a space station called the
Cloverfield remember that in the first
movie the government file about the
monster attack incident is called
Cloverfield that would imply that
humanity knows about some kind of
connection between this outer space
mission and the appearance of a creature
who will soon wreak havoc on the planet
and the bunker house in the second movie
is actually located at 10 Cloverfield
Lane but for now this just kind of seems
like a coincidence or is it now it is
I'm actually pretty sure it is early on
in the film the crew members of the
Cloverfield watch a news broadcast from
Earth it's an interview with a guy named
Mark Stambler played by actor Donal
Logue who has written a book warning
about the Cloverfield paradox hey just
like the title of the movie John
Goodman's character and 10 Cloverfield
Lane was named Howard Stambler mark we
presume is a relative to Howard in
addition to DNA probably they both share
a taste for conspiracy theories that
come true Mark Stambler has the twitter
address at paradox is real in the film
it's a real Twitter account but they
haven't posted anything yet okay so
that's it for fun little references but
I still have some questions on how
there's all links up to the incident as
seen in the other two Cloverfield movies
we learned from Mark Stambler that the
Sheppard accelerator could cause an
overlap of different dimensions opening
up a rip in the fabric of space-time
through which monsters or demons could
theoretically pass fair enough but the
original Cloverfield movie seems to
imply that the monsters came to earth
from outer space what about that little
projectile falling to the ground if the
monsters came through a rip in
space-time wouldn't they just suddenly
appear and the conclusion of 10
Cloverfield Lane made it look like there
were spaceships arriving
earth as well as if the monsters were
perhaps part of some kind of organized
alien invasion
maybe it wasn't aliens and maybe it was
just satellite plus the monster at the
end of Cloverfield paradox leaping up
above the clouds looks to be much larger
than the monster we originally saw in
Cloverfield I mean we don't know how
long the space station Cloverfield was
lost in an alternate dimension but could
it be this was months or even years
after the original incident also the
original movie Cloverfield set in 2008
and 10 Cloverfield Lane presumably set
in 2016
take place in our own time yet the
Cloverfield paradox has a bunch of semi
futuristic technology perhaps it's
sending monsters back through time or
the movies we've seen up until now were
set in alternate dimensions I think it
was alternate dimensions what do you
guys think the answer is we may never
know but we'd love to know if you have
any answers or connecting more dots than
we do let us know in the comments
[Applause]
you
[Applause]